[Music]
i knew i liked baking and i knew i was
good at it so i decided to start a
business off of it
there are people that are going through
a rough time and i just wanted to give
them something that i know they don't
get all the time they probably get soup
probably get a sandwich but i wanted to
give them something like cupcake
so every dessert that someone buys i
give dessert to someone in need
this great big story was made possible
by geico believe it geico could save you
15 or more on car insurance
[Music]
my name is michael platt and i am the
owner of michael's desserts
i was 11 years old when i started and
now i'm 14 years old
i was diagnosed with epilepsy when i was
eight or nine and it got me into bacon
because i was doing a bunch of other
stuff i was doing gymnastics i was
swimming climbing trees ride my bike
evelypsy put a bunch of restrictions on
those other things but there were no
tricks on baking
when i start baking i do like the flour
sugar eggs
butter and i'll put that in the oven for
15 minutes and then make the icing and
whatever i'm filling the cupcake with
[Music]
after the cupcakes have cool and
everything is made i will ice the
cupcake and packaging
[Music]
on average i go through probably 20
pounds of flour 15 pounds of sugar a
couple gallons of heavy cream and around
six boxes of cocoa powder per month
i sell around 170 cupcakes a month and
also means that i donate around 170
companies a month since the beginning
i've donated almost 10 000 cupcakes
[Music]
my parents got me a pair of tom shoes
for christmas and tom schue's business
model is one for one so i decided to do
that with my business so i deserve that
someone buys i give a dessert to someone
in need
most of the time i just go around dc
feeding the homeless or i'll go into
homeless shelters this is my way of
telling them that i haven't forgotten
about them it's also make sure i put
extra love and care to them to make sure
the people who are getting them into
them the best part for me is if i don't
feel like it if i'm tired i'm baking all
week just the thought that i am doing
this helps someone else just gets me up
and running it's like fuel
micro desserts is spelled with no
apostrophe and in grammar apostrophe
means ownership so i decided to do no
apostrophe because i wanted it to be a
reminder to me that i'm not doing this
for myself by doing it for other people
[Music]
[Music]
you